he's Antonio Brown speaking of Michigan
Central Michigan he's a Chippewa he got
find twenty thousand dollars for his end
zone dance the torque and then also the
shoes he was wearing special shoes and
Antonio Brown with Steelers joining us
what was worse getting fined for
twerking or the shoes you were wearing
uh what was worth probably Desmond I
know a lot of people wanted to call it
working but there's actually a
old-school Miami dance is called doodoo
brown growing up in Miami you know it's
a lot of chances as you coming up as a
kid got oh yeah we take we take
advantage of have fun with and something
we do for excitement the shoes you know
the shoes out meaning to me you know
there was Scott blue you know blue is
the color of freedom blue is the color
of water you know the sky and blue is a
sign of peace and / reality you know in
a court over the course of a game when I
get tired or will be on the long drive
and always like to wear something of
meaning to me you know the shoes have a
lot of minutes to me so when I look down
it remind me the stake center you know
state center within and go out and be my
best self you know those the reason why
I wear those shoes or long wear those
shoes for a fresh and shitty man I
should have where I'm last game man
probably why didn't have a big of a game
because uh I think we gotta as people we
gotta continue to do what means more to
us regardless of the price or what comes
along with it we got to be who we are
and do what memo stores are you going to
do it again me dancing and and or
wearing it includes yeah the right
moment you know I never want to cost my
team or be a distraction you know I play
football football as a game a team game
first off never about one guy you know
you need a total of
22 gods and special teams for compromise
or great team so now want to put the
team eraser bringing our attention to
myself but I'm always have fun and I'm
always do was important to me would you
grow up idolizing our girl otherwise and
Deion Sanders when you play the game the
way he made me feel watching the game
every time I watch them go back there
for a punt I knew there was the
opportunity that he'll score or I knew
he was would provide some type of sight
man as a kid being home in Liberty City
that would that would give me excited so
I grew up loving Dion did you want to
play defensive back as well I never
wanted to be a diva the back you know
always like to get the ball I'm always
definitely officer threat all the time I
just love the type of energy Dion birth
to the game all right how would Dion do
against you at dion's best man that'll
be exciting matchup I don't think that
make players like Dion anymore the type
of five made the type of competitiveness
the type of swagger I think the I had at
all I think it would be a great matchup
autoplay of a player will play against a
player of that type of stature not be a
fun matchup being at of his
competitiveness talent and I swagger
would have been pretty good to go yet
have you met him yeah I met him you know
I call them pop you know he texted me
every do every morning she always texts
me encourage encouragement inspiration
that uh help me stay positive without
the day that's pretty cool if I told you
a decade ago Dion's going to be in touch
with you all the time what would you
said I probably want to believe you know
growing up as a kid idolizes Deion
Sanders when is tennis shoes school
wearing a tennis shoe to play the
football games and being able to have
them communicate with me now oh
definitely a dream come true Antonio
Brown the steelers wide receiver joining
us Dan Patrick show do you have any
teammates he went to Oklahoma State
yeah I think Justin give a link Oklahoma
State then you of course went to Central
Michigan did you give him a little grief
after that ending absolutely you know he
i said the refs didn't give us a good
call but there's nothing new to us you
know Central Michigan beat been beating
big-time programs I tell lady I'm bill
all the time when I was there we beat
Michigan State I used to tell Brenda
well we beat Indiana you knowing some of
the matchups that we played in during my
course of time of being there that's
what we do man we just saw under rated
program that you just going to road and
just get one that's what the Chippewas
do antonio they just do what they do my
way yeah yep absolutely where's the
strangest place you've been recognized
strangest place over in recognize I'll
probably had a hockey game in the
bathroom what's the bathroom etiquette
to say hello to Antonio Brown please
don't take my hand oh my god reaches in
the background what's the best
conversation you've had with Ben
Roethlisberger during a game in the
huddle and the hollow yeah you guys talk
along the best conversation we had
private lab we lose a be shut up yeah
what do you wave no way through you one
and you dropped it though did he say
anything to you then my hair's say too
much tell me just relax you know over
the course of the game I'm used to
getting a ball a lot so usually when I
haven't touched the ball within like two
quarters I'm trying to get the ball and
do too much with it over the course of a
game you know my mom's contently working
I'm continually trying to visualize
myself doing things or catching the ball
and reacting and over the course of that
situation you know I gotta remember to
stay fundamental sound you know it catch
before I run explain this to me about
Josh Norman that he'll stay on one side
of the field Richard Sherman
I think most of the time stays on one
side of the field it seems to be such an
advantage for the offense that I can put
you wherever I want to and that doesn't
mean that Josh Norman or Richard
Sherman's going to cover you why is that
well i think you know in the NFL you
know being a great cornerback it's
really a great thing you know it gives
officer coordinators give quarterbacks
something to be alert of you know the
receiver always want to go against the
best guys and compete against those guys
101 because I know being a competitor
you want to work against the best and I
know that's what everyone wants to see
but uh being on the team where you got a
great quarterback and the grid office
coordinator they try to move the best
guy away from those guys and I don't
know what for you know you know whatever
guys that we need to attack guys and uh
you know let's go good on good you know
let's see what happens I know that
you're representing a glucose is that
right yes sir you want to explain it
glucose is a high-performance nutrients
company ideas so skewed I feel me before
working out gonna work out and post
games you could check out glucose energy
com a GU ill with a que OS click on
browse for glucose you can win glucose
with every reception every touchdown the
horny yard gain i get to send you a
grasp of glucose a great energy pack
water bottle and i was a great energy
source that continue to keep me few over
the course of a game it's glucose energy
commies Antonio Brown I picked you guys
to go to the Super Bowl and if you don't
go I'm going to hold you personally
accountable time I like that hey take
care good to hear from you thanks for
joining us thank you well the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience